PROFESSOR: How do we state
the issue of normalization?
See, the spherical harmonics
are functions of theta and phi.
So it makes sense that you would
integrate over theta and phi--
solid angle.
The solid angle is the
natural integration.
And it's a helpful integration,
because if you have solid angle
integrals and then
radial integrals,
you will have integrated
over all volume.
So for this spherical
harmonic, solid angle
is the right variable.
And you may remember,
if you have solid angle,
you have to integrate
over theta and phi.
Solid angle, you think
of it as a radius of one.
Here is sine theta.
So what is solid angle?
It's really the area on
a sphere of radius one.
The definition of
solid angle is area
over radius squared, the part of
the solid angle that you have.
If you're working with
a sphere of radius one,
it's the area element
is the solid angle.
So the area element in here
would be, or the integral
over solid angle--
this is solid angle, d omega--
you would integrate
from theta equals 0
to theta equals pi of
sine theta, d theta.
And then you would integrate
from 0 to 2 pi of d phi.
Now, you've seen that
this equation that
began as a differential equation
for functions of theta ending
up being the
differential equation
for a function of cosine theta.
Cosine theta was
the right variable.
Well, here it is as well,
and you should always
recognize that.
This is minus d of cosine theta.
And here you would be degrading
from cosine theta equals 1
to minus 1.
But the minus and the order of
integration can be reversed,
so you have the integral from
minus 1 to 1 of d cos theta
and then the integral
from 0 to 2 pi of alpha.
So this is the solid
angle integral.
You integrate d of cosine
theta from minus 1 to 1 and 0
to 2 pi of d phi.
And we will many times use
this notation, the omega,
to represent that integral so
that we don't have to write it.
But when we have to
write it, we technically
prefer to write it this way,
so that the integrals should
be doable in terms
of cosine theta.
So what does this all mean
for our spherical harmonics?
Well, our spherical
harmonics turned out
to be eigenfunctions
or Hermitian operators.
And if they have different
l's and m's, they
are having different
eigenvalues.
So eigenfunctions of
Hermitian operators
with different eigenvalues
have to be orthogonal.
So we'll write the
main property, which
is the integral of
2l, say l prime, m
prime, of theta and phi.
And he put the star here.
I'll put the star just
at the Y, and he's
complex conjugated
the whole thing.
Remember that in our problem,
one wave function was complex
conjugated.
The other wave function
is not complex conjugated.
They're different
ones because l and m
and l prime and m prime
could be different.
So orthogonality is warranted.
Two different ones with
different l's and different m's
should give you different
values of this integral.
So at this moment, you
should get a delta l prime l
delta m prime m.
And if l and m are the same
as l prime and m prime,
you have the same
spherical harmonic.
And all this tremendous
formula over there,
with 2l plus 1 and
all these figures,
you're guaranteed that in
that case you get 1 here.
So this formula is
correct as written.
That is the orthonormality
of this solution.
Probably, this stage might
be a little vague for you.
We saw this a long time ago.
We may want to review
why eigenfunctions
of Hermitian operators
with different eigenvalues
are orthogonal and see
if you could prove.
And you do it, or is it kind
of a little fuzzy already?
We saw it over a month ago.
So time to go back to
the Schrodinger equation.
So for that, we
remember what we have.
We have minus h squared over
2m Laplacian of psi plus V of r
psi equals E psi.
And the Laplacian has
this form, so that we can
write it the following way--
minus h squared over 2m 1 over
r d second dr squared r psi--
I won't close the
brackets here--
minus this term.
So I'll write it minus one
over h squared r squared l
squared psi plus V of r
psi is equal to E psi.
Now, you could be a little
concerned doing operators
and say, well, am I
sure this l squared
is to the right
of the r squared?
r and l-- l has momentum.
Momentum [INAUDIBLE] with r.
Maybe there's a problem there.
But rest assured, there
is no problem whatsoever.
You realize that l squared was
all these things with dd phetas
and dd phis.
There was no r in there.
It commutes with it.
There is no ambiguity.
We can prove directly that
l squared commutes with r,
and it takes a little more work.
But you've seen
what l squared is.
It's the dd thetas and dd phis.
It just doesn't have
anything to do with it.
So now for the great
simplification.
You don't want any of your
variables in this equation.
You want to elicit
to a radial equation.
So we try a factorized solution.
Psi is going to be--
of all the correlates--
is going to be a product
a purely radial wave
function of some energy E
times a Ylm of theta and phi.
And we can declare
success if we can
get from this
differential equation now
a radial differential
equation, just for r.
Forget thetas and phi.
All that must have been taken
care of by the angular momentum
operators.
And we have hoped for that.
In fact, if you look at it, you
realize that we've succeeded.
Why?
The right-hand side will have
a factor of y and m untouched.
V of r times psi will have
a factor of Ylm untouched.
This term, having
just r derivatives
will have some things acting
on this capital R and Ylm
untouched.
The only problem is this one.
But l squared on Ylm
is a number times Ylm.
It's one of our eigenstates.
Therefore, the Y's and
m's drop out completely
from this equation.
And what do we get?
Well, you get minus h squared
over 2m 1 over r, d second,
dr squared, r capital RE
minus l squared on psi lm--
or Ylm now--
is h squared times
l times l plus 1.
So the h squared cancels.
You get l times l
plus 1 r squared,
and then we get the RE
of r times the psi lm
that has already--
I started to cancel it
from the whole equation.
So I use here that L squared
from the top blackboard
over there, has that eigenvalue,
and the psi lm has dropped out.
Then I have the V of r
RE equals E time RE of r.
So this is great.
We have a simplified equation,
all the angular dependencies
gone.
I now have to solve this
equation for the radial wave
function and then multiply
it by a spherical harmonic.
And I got a solution
that represents
a state of the system
with angular momentum l
and with z component
of angular momentum m.
The only thing I
have to do, however,
is to clean up this
equation a little bit.
And the way to clean it up is
to admit that, probably, it's
better as an equation
for this product.
So let's clean it up by
multiplying everything by r.
dr squared of little r RE.
If I multiplied
by r here, I will
have plus h squared
over 2m l times
l plus 1 over r squared
rRE plus V of r times
r times RE equals E
times r times RE of r.
So we'll call u of r r times RE
of r, and look what we've got.
We've got something
that has been adjusted,
but things worked out
to look just right.
Minus h squared over 2m
d second, dr squared u
of r plus--
let me open a parentheses V
of r plus h squared over 2m r
squared, l times l plus one u
of r is equal to E times u of r.
Here it is.
It's just a nice form of a
one-dimensional Schrodinger
equation.
The radial equation for the wave
function dependents, a long r,
has become a radial
one-dimensional particle
in that potential, in which
you should remember two things.
That this u is not quite
the full radial dependent.
The radial dependent is
RE, which is u over r.
But this equation
is just very nice.
And what you see is
another important thing.
If you look at the given
particle in a potential,
you have many options.
You can look first for the
states that have 0 angular
momentum-- l equals zero--
and you must solve
this equation.
Then you must look
at l equals 1.
There can be states
with l equals one.
And then you must
solve it again.
And then you must solve for
l equals 2 and for l equals 3
and for all values of l.
So actually, yes, the
three-dimensional problem
is more complicated than
the one-dimensional problem,
but only because, in
fact, solving a problem
means learning how to solve
it for all values of l.
Now, you will
imagine that if you
learn how to solve for one
value of l, solving for another
is not that different.
And that's roughly true, but
there's still differences.
l equals 0 is the easiest thing.
So if the particle is
in three dimensions
but has no angular
momentum-- and remember,
l equals 0 means no angular
momentum-- it's this case.
l equals 0 means m equals 0.
l squared is 0.
lz is 0.
This is 0 angular momentum.